STUDENT: I had two slightly related questions--
I guess the first one is, we were talking about how--
well, this could be the resurgence of religion is--
could be the last gasp of religion. And I was wondering what exactly are the
proofs or justifications of that? Especially when we were talking about how, because of globalization,
people are looking back to religion and relying more and more on it. And I guess I'll pose my other question later.
VOLF: Yeah.
So what are some of the indicators?
Well, I mean, you can-- say, take Europe as paradigmatic.
What's gonna happen
as
countries develop, as nations develop, in the course of globalization processes?
Well, you can look at Sweden. I think the church attendance is about 2-3%.
You look
at Great Britain, I think church attendance there is somewhere around 5 or so percent?
And you can go down the line. Not just true of the Protestant
nations, it's also true of the Catholic ones. In Italy, it's dropping rapidly; in
Spain, it's dropping rapidly.
These countries are secularizing,
and the theory then was: this is really what happens when you give modernization
a chance, right? Just let it sit for a while
and have its impact,
it's going to erode religious convictions.
That's often paired
with the idea of what function
it is
that religion fulfills, right?
And the claim that these functions
that religion in primitive societies for primitive people fulfilled--
will be fulfilled, we can show how they will be fulfilled, by other--
by forces of modernization. Easy access to medicine,
social care, and so forth and so forth. And you will basically not need
religion. So you have an account of
how societies develop,
and what it is that creates a need for religion,
and you say, "Well,
it's most likely that's exactly what's gonna happen
in other countries as well."
So that's, I think, roughly-- and sociologists of religion,
great sociologists, have believed this for roughly 200 years, you know?
So
we are now realizing that that might not be the case, and only recently we have these theories
of multiple modernities,
studying very carefully how different societies
modernize and what happens to them when they modernize.
United States was seen as always as an anomaly,
and needed some explaining, and explanations were offered-- but Europe was the paradigm. Now
Now it's inverted. Now the United States seems more like a--
as a paradigm,
and Europe,
for whatever reason, is seen to be anomalous in terms of developments
because we see
analogous things happening in other countries as we see in the United States.
Now, that's on this side, right?
Contest on the side
of advocate of multiple modernities.
Others will say, "Even the United States-- give it time.
It's gonna go down.
And some indicators are there that
religious observance, for whatever reasons, is over-reported in the United States.
The United States is much less religious of a country
than it's claimed that it is. So the debate goes back and forth.